an essay by Sierra Tabrizi a research
fellow at the Royal United Services
Institute joins us from London Anna cbcr
it's a breezy it's the 2015 deal in
effect dead and gone
not yet but of course the latest
announcement made by Iran doesn't make
the situation easier to deal with for
the remaining parties we know that the
situation has been very complicated
since President Trump has been in power
and especially since the u.s. withdrew
from the nuclear deal in May two
thousand eighteen and of course
attention that reason even more over the
past six months since Iran has decided
to scale back its compliance with the
nuclear deal in response to the maximum
pressure campaign and to the fact that
it was not getting the benefit of
remaining fully compliant to the nuclear
deal pardon me for interrupting you why
is Iran doing this as of now well the
rationale behind Iran's behavior has
been clear since May they have decided
to take these steps because they are not
able to sell their oil or to be
connected to the financial system and
have been saying that if they are not
able to sell their oil or to get the
benefit of a transaction with the global
financial system there is no benefit for
them to remain a party of the nuclear
deal and they have been trying to push
the III in particular but also Russia
and China to find ways to basically
offset the impact of US sanctions but as
of now 6 min six months after Iran made
his announcement there has been still no
change in the situation as far as the
other signatories are concerned if there
are back-channel conversations going on
because Tehran is clearly signaling look
it's not completely dead and buried as
of yet what's the nature of those
conversations well we know that the
remaining parties are committed to to
the nuclear deal as they are committed
to bring Iran back
full compliance to the nocardia these
are the two priorities we also know that
in particular the e3 UK France and
Germany have tried to find ways for Iran
to continue trade with Europe but also
with other countries we know about the
insect's mechanism and the EU blocking
statute all of that however
unfortunately because of the nature of
the u.s. legislation has not been
sufficient to allow Iran to continue its
deals with the UN with other countries
so the nature of the conversation right
now is to see if there are quicker fixes
quicker incentives for Iran to be
convinced to go back to its full
compliance of course the latest
announcement made by Iran it's going to
be taken very seriously by the EU and
Russia and China as well because of the
sensitivity of for doe and what it
entails back in 2009 with regard to the
20 percent enrichment so we don't have
to see whether Iran went too far in
trying to push the remaining parties in
delivering something in return for its
full compliance and whether the jcpoa
will say alive or not
okay speculate for us then it will be
complete speculation of course what do
you think the Washington reaction will
be to this Donald Trump's reaction will
be as the states wakes up to this news
john bolton national security adviser
very right-wing he's not in the picture
anymore
well we know that in reality what the
president Trumbull would want is for
Iran to negotiate a new deal however the
u.s. strategy so far has been of maximum
pressure only of imposition of sanctions
and of jeopardizing their strategy and
attempts of partners and allies is a
such a European one to keep the deal
alive so we know they're not going to be
very happy about the news but this is
part of the maximum pressure campaign
and a result of basically putting off a
number of sanctions without anything in
return for Iran to consider even for
coming to the negotiating table so I
hope and would assume that there should
be some sort of rethinking about the
strategy and that this will be done in
coordination with the European partners
nsab said it's a breezy there in London
thank you very much